okay our our last topic uh in today's
lab um is one not really specific to
support Vector classifiers but these uh
Roc curves or receiver operator
characteristic curves and they are a way
to sort of summarize uh the performance
of a classifier at you know at many
different levels in chapter 4 we saw
that for a classifier that say predicts
probability of being in a class you
could vary the threshold and that would
give you different uh you know different
predictions and of course for every
value prediction there's a different uh
accuracy or a different false positive
rate Etc so the RC curve sort of
summarizes these this accuracy um as a
function of the threshold implic um
okay so we're going to use a function um
this Roc curve display comes from the
pyit learn metrics package and we're
going to it's we're going to use this
this uh Mees me method called from
estimator so what what this does we're
going to give it a classifier that's an
a py learn estimator that produces
something like a a a thresh threshold of
probability that we can use to to vary
the threshold and Trace out a curve of
the accuracy as the parameter changes
and of course I should say that this is
the RLC curve is really meant for binary
data because that's one where you can
sort of Simply describe the performance
of the classifier by the accuracy
okay so our estimator this was the tune
support Vector machine we saw just above
and we're going to evaluate well we can
evaluate an Roc curve on the training
data or the test data first we'll
evaluate one on the training data and
when we evaluate later on test a we'd
expect it to do not as well and we'll
see that as
well
okay so this makes a plot that has um
two quantities two two axes the true
positive rate on the y- axis and the
false positive rate on the negative axis
so a good classifier is you know
something that's high up in this corner
it has very high true positive rate
that's measure of the power and very low
false positive rate that's a measure of
the the type one err or the the false
positive and since this was done on the
training data of course it does really
well yes yeah and so there's another
there's a a summary that people provide
of the RLC curve called the area under
the curve and that's just the area under
this red curve and it's about 99 % for
reference a random pure random guessing
should be about 50% so this is you know
qu quite close to perfect okay and a
perfect classifier will get 100%
yes okay
um
so we're going to make a few plots on uh
training and test data we are going to
um here we've changed the classifier a
little bit but I want to focus here on
the difference between training and test
rather than on the classifier so here uh
we'll fit this new support Factor
machine on um on our training data and
of course it was chosen to be quite
flexible so here's one as we saw before
a really good classifier can get 100%
And um well that's 100% on training data
of course we' have to see whether how
well it does on test
data okay so now let's make the same
plot but use test data instead of
training data and we're going to plotter
on the same plot by giving it this axis
argument
you'll see actually there are a lot of
lot of functions around in Python that
produce plots that you can give this
axis argument to and remember that the
axis is actually the the thing where you
actually make plots on so you can use
this to add features you know to add
things to a plot um and most of things
like scikit learn and and pandas use
this act argument so you can add this RC
curve to an existing plot for instance
and I'm going to redis redisplay the
figure with this this fig uh dang Ling
reference and that just produces the
figure in the
notebook okay um so here instead of the
flexible one we'll look at the the act
the plot for the the the tuned one and
red is the training data and blue is the
test data and as we expect the blue one
does slightly worse than the red one
because of course it's test data it
still does quite well an AOC of about
90%
here okay so that about wraps up what
we're going to disc discuss today there
there's another Topic in the lab that is
uh support Factor SC with multiple
classes uh that we encourage you to do
offline